les élus locaux soutiennent dit il mais
à paris la gauche me condamne un extrait
de ces échanges
comment se fait-il qu'ils aient temps de
décalage entre les déclarations
nationales de certaines formations
politiques et le comportement local de
maire et de député et même vous monsieur
le président du groupe socialiste à
l'assemblée nationale et maire de nantes
vous fait des déclarations définitives
sur la politique de sécurité du
gouvernement
mais quand je suis à nantes vous
féliciter à juste titre de l'action du
gir de nantes qui a démantelé un réseau
humain
oui mesdames et messieurs j'ai dit
effectivement nos publiquement au
ministre que la façon dont les choses se
passaient se passait dans l'intérêt du
droit et de la république et qu'il ne
faisait que son travail mère et je
trouve que la façon dont il vient de
procéder est pas une façon courait du
point de vue des institutions
républicains restent euros monsieur le
président je tiens qu'il soit marqué au
procès verbal que ce type de procédé
vise d'abord et avant tout à bâillonner
la voix de l'opposition
elle est là pour faire son travail elle
le fera merci monsieur ayrault voilà
encore un mot pour vous dire que nicolas
sarkozy sera notre invité demain à
l'occasion de la présentation de ce
projet de loi au conseil des ministres